Dos nuevos países han surgido en el tablero
político mundial.
O al menos en el mapamundi ruso.
El pasado lunes 21 de febrero, el presidente
de la Federación Ruso, Vladimir Putin firmó
los decretos que reconocen la independencia
de la República Popular de Donetsk y la República
Popular de Lugansk en el este de Ucrania.
Y eso no es todo:
El presidente ruso también le ordenó a su
Ministro de Defensa el despliegue inmediato
del ejército ruso en estas dos nuevas repúblicas
para llevar a cabo una “operación de mantenimiento
de la paz”.
Lo que, por supuesto, en palabras de Putin,
significa demostrar que controlas el territorio.
De hecho, en esta misma línea, el propio
gobierno ruso ha enviado a la Duma, para su
ratificación, los tratados de defensa alcanzados
con las nuevas repúblicas populares.
Dos tratados, que por supuesto y como no podía
ser de otra manera, le encargan a Moscú la
protección de estos territorios, le facultan
para desplegar tropas y le permiten construir
bases militares en ellos.
[Vamos, que estamos ante una de esas grandes
obras de teatro que tanto gustan en Moscú]
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os contamos cómo
esta jugada, el reconocimiento pleno de la
independencia de estas dos “repúblicas”
era algo más que probable.
Por así decirlo es una jugada que forma parte
del manual habitual de Moscú.
Es algo que ya hemos visto en los casos de
Transnistria, Abjasia y Osetia del Sur.
Con todo el despliegue de tropas rusas en
las autoproclamadas repúblicas populares
de Donetsk y Lugansk supone la primera incursión
formal de tropas rusas en territorio legalmente
ucraniano y una violación flagrante de los
acuerdos de Minsk II.
Algo que ha disparado la tensión y el miedo
a que esta operación sea solo el preludio
de una invasión a gran escala de Ucrania.
Lo que por cierto sigue siendo negado por
el presidente de Ucrania, Volodymyr Zelenskiy.
Bajo su punto de vista este movimiento, a
pesar de suponer una clara violación de la
soberanía ucraniana y de los acuerdos de
Minsk II, simplemente ha “legalizado”
la actividad que el ejercito ruso lleva realizando
en la región desde el año 2014.
La realidad que todo el mundo conocía, que
Moscú negaba y que ahora nos alarma que se
haya confirmado.
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta como Moscú
ha rodeado Ucrania por tierra, mar y aire:
Sea como sea, el caso, amigos, es que toda
esta situación pone sobre la mesa unas cuantas
preguntas:
¿Qué consecuencias puede tener este reconocimiento?
¿Qué supone para el conflicto entre Rusia,
Ucrania y Occidente?
Y la pregunta que a la hora de la verdad puede
que a muchos más o pique la curiosidad:
¿Cómo son exactamente estas repúblicas?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
(LAS NUEVAS REPÚBLICAS POPULARES)
Desde su autoproclamada independencia en el
año 2014 las nuevas repúblicas han quedado
aisladas casi por completo del resto de Ucrania
y prácticamente de todo el mundo con la excepción,
claro está, de Rusia.
Hoy forman uno de los territorios más opacos,
cerrados y militarizados de todo el planeta.
La República Popular de Donetsk tiene unos
8.900km2 (8.902km2) y unos 2,3 millones de
habitantes.
Este hombre que veis en pantalla, Denis Pushilin,
que formó parte de una enorme estafa piramidal
en Rusia y Ucrania es su líder.
Por su parte la República Popular de Lugansk
tiene unos 8.300km2 (8.377km2) y 1,6 millones
de habitantes.
En total hablamos de unos 17.300 km2, el equivalente
a la superficie de Kuwait o Swazilandia y
3,9 millones de habitantes.
Aunque la población podría ser en realidad
muy inferior.
Digamos que resulta difícil de precisar por
los enormes desplazamientos de población
del conflicto que arrancó en el año 2014.
El año que dio forma a estas dos nuevas repúblicas.
El día 22 febrero del año 2014, el por aquel
entonces presidente de Ucrania y aliado de
Moscú, Viktor Yanukovich, huyó de la capital
y dejó su puesto como consecuencia de las
protestas desatadas por la Revolución del
Euromaidán.
Y ahí, justo ahí es cuando comenzó la tormenta.
(Rusia, respondió a la revolución del Euromaidán
anexionándose Crimea con los famosos hombres
de verde y alimentando la sublevación del
este del país.
Sin embargo, si la toma de Crimea fue limpia,
los levantamientos en el este de Ucrania fueron
un caos.
Las protestas en Donetsk y Lugansk pronto
dieron paso a un conflicto armado entre el
nuevo gobierno de Ucrania y las milicias locales
respaldadas por Moscú.
Inicialmente los rebeldes prorrusos avanzaron
rápido y se hicieron con el control de la
práctica totalidad de los Oblast de Donetsk
y Lugansk.
Sin embargo, el contraataque del ejército
ucraniano y particularmente de los batallones
de voluntarios obligaron a Rusia a enviar
tanques, baterías antiaéreas y artillería
de largo alcance para frenar la ofensiva y
obligar a Ucrania a pactar un alto el fuego
y firmar los acuerdos de Minsk II.
Desde entonces la línea del frente se ha
mantenido más o menos estable.)
Los acuerdos de Minsk II fueron un intento
de poner fin al conflicto.
Impulsados por Francia y Alemania con el escepticismo
de Estados Unidos, el acuerdo reconocía la
soberanía ucraniana a cambio de Kiev le otorgará
a las regiones sublevadas un status de autonomía
especial.
Claro que las definiciones fueron imprecisas
y al final ninguna de las partes cumplió
su palabra.
En cualquier caso, si hoy por hoy algo está
claro es que, por mucho que moleste en Bruselas,
una vez que Rusia ha reconocido la plena independencia
de las Repúblicas Populares de Donetsk y
Lugansk, estos acuerdos ya no valen nada,
son papel mojado.
Además, el conflicto nunca se terminó.
El fuego de francotiradores y los intercambios
de artillería fueron constantes por ambos
bandos.
En total se calcula que esta guerra ha causado
entre 14.000 y 20.000 víctimas mortales,
además de por lo menos 2 millones de desplazados.
[En otras palabras, que los acuerdos de Minsk
II fueron otra de esas grandilocuentes operaciones
europeas repletas de buenas intenciones pero
que a la hora de la verdad nadie se las cree,
ni siquiera los propios firmantes.]
El caso es que así es como surgieron las
nuevas repúblicas populares de Donetsk y
Lugansk.
Dos repúblicas que viven prácticamente bajo
un estado de guerra.
Las instituciones fueron asaltadas; se impuso
un modelo ultranacionialis, conservador y
militarizado; y muchas, por no decir, la mayoría
de las grandes empresas y los activos productivos,
como las minas o las fábricas de acero, fueron
expropiadas o puestas a disposición de oligarcas
amigos de Moscú.
Este es por ejemplo el caso de Yevgeni Yurchenko,
un inversor ruso que ahora controla los activos
más valiosos.
Y sí, también han establecido un modelo
político-policial de mano dura.
C1("Han logrado reconstruir un sistema soviético
en los territorios ocupados, y no el sistema
soviético de las décadas de 1960 y 1970,
sino el sistema soviético de las décadas
de 1930 y 1940, con mazmorras, con cámaras
de tortura, un sistema donde las vidas se
arruinan si te atreves a escribir o decir
algo negativo sobre estas repúblicas y sus
autoridades".
Stanislav Aseev, novelista y periodista de
Donetsk)
Y ojo porque hablamos del que era uno de los
territorios más desarrollados de toda Ucrania.
Por supuesto, tal y como os podéis imaginar,
todo esto ha tenido consecuencias.
Atentos.
2(LA RUINA)
Hace apenas una década, Donetsk fue una de
las sedes más importantes de la Eurocopa
del año 2012 que fue organizada por Ucrania
y Polonia.
Para albergar esta competición la ciudad
se vistió de gala: se restauró buena parte
de la ciudad, se construyó un nuevo aeropuerto,
se arreglaron las carreteras y se abrieron
nuevos y relucientes hoteles.
Tampoco resultaba extraño.
Las regiones de Donetsk y Lugansk, formaban
el conocido como cinturón del óxido, el
motor económico de toda Ucrania, un importante
enclave minero e industrial, hogar de las
mayores acerías del país.
Donetsk también era el hogar y principal
sede del emporio de EE, el hombre más rico
de Ucrania, un multimillonario cuya fortuna
Forbes calcula en unos 7.000 millones de dólares
Hoy todo eso ha quedado atrás.
Las infraestructuras están destrozadas, el
servicio de telefonía móvil e internet es
irregular en el mejor de los casos, la actividad
económica se ha desplomado, los empleos desaparecido
y cerca de la mitad, ojo la mitad de la población
podría haber emigrado al resto de Ucrania,
a Rusia o al resto de Europa, sobre todo a
Polonia.
Por supuesto, las empresas y las cadenas internacionales
han cerrado sus puertas a cal y canto.
C2(“Solía haber mucho entusiasmo por la
república popular de Donetsk al principio,
¡todos coreaban DPR, DPR, DPR!
Ahora, solo hay mucha decepción.
[...] La economía allí se ha desmoronado,
los puestos de trabajo se han ido.
No hay nada bueno allí”.
Oleksandr Gayevoy, exiliado de la región
de Donetsk)
Hoy estas 2 repúblicas son territorios muy
pobres que viven esencialmente del contrabando
y de la financiación rusa.
Y es que de hecho en ellas todo es Rusia:
la moneda de curso oficial es el rublo, a
sus ciudadanos se les expide pasaportes rusos,
tienen acceso a los beneficios sociales de
Rusia y sus mandatarios se han unido al partido
político de Putin.
[Vamos, que lo de la independencia es un poco
de broma.
Hablamos mejor, y si eso, de autonomía como
mucho.]
(El futuro además no parece nada halagüeño.
Sin reconocimiento internacional las inversiones
y el comercio lo tiene muy complicado.
Para colmo, tras el reconocimiento de su independencia
por parte de Rusia, el presidente Joe Biden
ha firmado una orden ejecutiva que prohíbe
que cualquier empresa, entidad o ciudadano
de Estados Unidos participe directa o indirectamente
en proyectos de inversión, exportaciones,
importaciones, financiación o cualquier otro
negocio con estos territorios.
Donetsk y Lugansk han quedado aislados de
la comunidad internacional.
Lo que hasta hace poco fue el lugar más próspero
de Ucrania hoy es una enorme ruina.)
Curiosamente, han sido las ciudades ucranianas
del Donbass las que han salido más favorecidas.
Hablamos de ciudades que en los últimos años
han recibido montones de trabajadores y empresarios
de las zonas controladas por Rusia.
Este es por ejemplo el caso de Járkov, la
segunda ciudad más poblada de Ucrania.
Una ciudad que históricamente ha estado muy
ligada a Rusia y que fue uno de los principales
centros de producción militar soviética.
Una ciudad que los rebeldes prorrusos ocuparon
brevemente en 2014 hasta que fueron expulsados
por una fuerza de acción rápida del ejército
ucraniano.
Hablamos de una ciudad donde se calcula que
en 2014 apenas un tercio de la población
era leal al gobierno ucraniano.
Un porcentaje que ahora se podría haber incrementado
por encima del 70% gracias a lo diferente
que ha sido su evolución económica respecto
a la que han tenido los territorios en mano
de los rebeldes prorrusos.
Sí, el mayor enemigo para Moscú puede ser,
precisamente, la falta de futuro que entraña
su ocupación.
Viendo como están las cosas en la propia
Rusia, ¿Cómo no van a mirar los ucranianos
hacía el oeste?
Es de cajón.
Ahora bien, llegados hasta aquí ¿qué supone
exactamente el reconocimiento de Rusia?
¿Por qué ha generado tanta alarma?
Bien, en primer lugar porque la “operación
para el mantenimiento de la paz”, ejem,
ejem, supone la primera incursión reconocida
de tropas rusas en territorio ucraniano, pero
también porque tarde o temprano podría actuar
como una excusa perfecta para la invasión
o cuanto menos para mantener la tensión al
rojo vivo.
Fijaos por ejemplo en este mapa.
En él podéis ver en color más oscuro el
territorio controlado por las repúblicas
populares.
Y en color más claro el territorio que reclaman.
La cuestión es, ¿el reconocimiento ruso
afecta también a este territorio en disputa?
De ser así, podríamos estar ante la justificación
de una invasión, o acciones de agresión
por parte de las milicias de las repúblicas
populares que terminaran con el apoyó de
Moscú.
(Rusia respalda las reclamaciones territoriales
completas de los separatistas de Ucrania)
(Putin ha dicho públicamente que Rusia respalda
todas las reivindicaciones territoriales de
los separatistas prorrusos.
Eso sí, también dijo que correspondía a
los separatistas negociar con Kiev la forma
de resolver esta disputa fronteriza.
Eso puede significar dos cosas.
Por un lado, la excusa perfecta para lanzar
una invasión parcial sobre todo el Donbass
y quizás también las costas del Mar Negro
si el ejercito ucraniano muestra resistencia.
Por otro, puede ser la fórmula escogida para
elevar aún más la tensión, intentar lograr
un tanto político en la mesa de negociación
y guardarse la baza de la invasión para el
futuro.)
Si esto es así, la presencia de tropas rusas
no tendría porqué suponer ningún cambio.
Putin podría apuntarse el tanto que tanto
está buscando en casa y podría evitar la
mayoría de las sanciones internacionales.
(22/02: Joe Biden impone una ola de sanciones
a Rusia por la "invasión" de Ucrania.
El presidente de los Estados Unidos se dirige
a las élites, algunos bancos y la deuda soberana
y dice que seguirán más medidas si Putin
avanza.
FT)
(Australia, Canadá y Japón imponen sanciones
a Rusia por la crisis de Ucrania)
En este caso el resultado para Rusia seguirá
siendo malo, como ya os contamos en un pasado
vídeo, pero los daños podrían ser limitados.
Claro que si finalmente el Kremlin decide
ir más allá, bueno las experiencias de Donetsk
y Lugansk no permiten ser optimistas con el
futuro de los ucranianos.
Y tampoco con el de los propios rusos: no
ganaran nada y perderán mucho.
Además, por supuesto, de una rotunda condena
internacional.
C3("Tenemos información creíble que indica
que las fuerzas rusas están creando listas
de ucranianos identificados para ser asesinados
o enviados a campamentos después de una ocupación
militar.
[..] Es probable que las fuerzas rusas utilicen
medidas letales para dispersar protestas pacíficas
o contrarrestar de otra manera los ejercicios
pacíficos de resistencia percibida de las
poblaciones civiles".
Bathsheba Crocker, embajador de Estados Unidos
ante la oficina de las Naciones Unidas)
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti:
¿Cómo piensas que van a discurrir los acontecimientos?¿Será
la intervención en estas dos autoproclamadas
repúblicas populares el preludio de acciones
mayores?
Dejanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like.
Muy pronto os hablaremos con todo detalle
del caso de Georgia, así que no olvides suscribirte
si aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.